[Music]
the smp has been in power in hollywood
for 15 years now in this week's magazine
james heal the spectators diary editor
and michael simmons our data journalist
write that nicholas sturgeon has created
one of the most opaque and centralized
governments in europe
to discuss james joins me now alongside
jackie bailey deputy leader of scottish
labour
james and jackie thanks for joining me
on spectator tv
james you along with our colleague
michael simmons write this week about
the quote poor planning willful waste
and absence of accountability end quote
of the scottish national party over the
past 15 years in power
what in your view has gone so badly
wrong
okay i think a number of things have
gone wrong up in scotland um i think the
danger is that secret government tends
to lead to bad government with a lack of
transparency accountability mechanisms
for some of the failures so those
failures are repeated and exacerbated
and the focal point for this story was
looking at the um ferguson shipyard and
what's gone wrong there and now this is
sort of eight years of delay uh
misspending and the original budget for
these two original vessels has gone from
97 million to 240 million
and so what the real issue is that not
things that have gone wrong but that
these failures have been exacerbated by
a failure to learn from mistakes and the
danger you have with the s p i think is
a party that's been in power 15 years
now and a tendency to think of itself as
the state and the danger is that any
criticism is seen as somehow treason
and therefore you do not learn from
what's gone wrong previously and um it
just means a failure to learn and that's
why scotland i think is suffering in its
public sector outcomes
jackie is james being unfair i mean
things go wrong all the time in the
public sector doesn't necessarily mean
that something particularly sinister is
going on
no i think he's perhaps being overly
generous if i could put it that way you
know i've been in the scottish
parliament since 1999 the very beginning
and i have never seen a more
centralizing more secretive government
than the one that's currently in power
um and james is right they simply do not
accept they make mistakes or indeed
learn from them
and what we're witnessing now is very
much a
centralizing command and control
structure that's controlled by nicolas
sturgeon at the very top
dissent is just not allowed debate is
stifled
and the committees of the parliament do
not have teeth they don't seem to be
able to challenge the first minister
because of course the snp majority votes
as one you know we don't have
independent members on committees they
are very much creatures of their own
party if you take the ferguson shipyard
contract as an example but it is
excessively over budget
documents are missing that would tell us
what actually happened
and it seems to be
that key points in the contract were
based on
snp conference or the referendum and if
you look at the timeline there's
certainly in my view
not just serial incompetence which is
what i used to think it was but actually
an abuse of power and it is a
disgraceful scandal and
nobody is shedding light on it and we
need to understand the truth of what
went on james can you talk a bit about
nicholas sturgeon's office which you and
michael mentioned in the piece how it
works and why you think it differs from
number 10 i mean is it really any more
secretive than what's happening in
whitehall
well i think in whitehall you certainly
have a degree to which is based on a
balance of power you know you have the
treasury you have the foreign office you
have a number of different whitehall
departments competing and some might say
that kind of competition does produce at
least a degree of accountability whereby
you know you have a number of different
ministers you can hold that prime
minister to account you know the prime
minister here for instance london
doesn't even have a department of his
own whereas in scotland if you talk to
civil servants people involved in the
government there i mean nicola sturgeon
sort of looms like a zeppelin over the
whole thing
very even sort of minor decisions get
signed off by the first minister which
is why some people find it hard to
believe that in the ferguson shipyard
she wasn't involved in signing off any
of it and that's why i've seen a lot of
the briefings going on and a lot of the
kind of spin that's happened um because
of what's happened and what i think is
most important kate is that the scottish
government was set up and the scottish
apartment was set up in 1999 and there
was a real hope and expectation about it
here was a chance for scotland and
hollywood to do much better than
westminster and the sad thing is that
nicola sturgeon a woman who was elected
in 2014 as first minister to be the most
quote accessible first minister ever
hasn't lived up to that expectation and
promise and that kind of self-renewal
that was hoped for with the s p
when she was named first minister after
alex salmon left hasn't really taken
place and so i think the difference
between the aspiration and reality or
the rhetoric of reality is what is most
damning about what's going on in
scotland jackie james writes about
sturgeon's latest idea as part of a
pandemic law the scottish government
would be able to modify or amend any act
of parliament without a vote
what do you make of those plans are they
a non-starter in hollywood
i mean frankly i find them quite
extraordinary um it is astonishing
what's being described as sweeping henry
viii powers
that the scottish government is seeking
will enable them without scrutiny
without approval of the scottish
parliament to simply change existing
primary legislation in whatever way they
wish now i think that frankly is just a
power grab too far um if you look at the
consultation civic scotland is opposed
to this in fact i think 80 if not 90
percent of the respondents said that
this just went too far
and was not appropriate unfortunately
the snp now have a majority in the
parliament alongside their partners the
greens and so this will go through
unless we can make sufficient noise to
stop it from happening but it is quite
extraordinary that they now disregard
the parliament completely even during
the pandemic whilst it is appropriate to
give people emergency powers and the
parliament was able to do that quite
quickly and the reality is when it comes
to lane regulations they lay them and
only see parliamentary approval after
the event that's not a smart way of
doing it if you want to take everybody
with you but as you say jackie the snp
has their majority you can make a lot of
noise but realistically is there much
more that you could do to stop them
well i think and what we've sought to do
is when you find that the government
isn't listening then actually making
common cause with civic scotland with
the experts and the professionals
whether it's in academia or in business
actually bears fruit because if the
entire country is saying this is not the
way to do things
then i do think any government including
nicolas sturgeon's government really
need to sit up and listen um but but i
live in hope that that might happen but
at the moment what we're seeing is spin
and assertion over evidence and scrutiny
and it's really depressing because
devolution could be so much better than
this james you and michael write that
there are structural problems in the
scottish parliament too you write about
the warnings that snps were given during
the alex salmon trial for example
yes i mean i think that jackie touched
on an important point which is that you
know as long as you can the the one big
thing with the scottish electoral system
was that no one people thought that no
one ever get a majority but once you've
got that effectively there aren't many
checks or balances you know compared to
westminster where you've got for
instance the house of lords we've got a
much more dynamic political culture in
terms of you know back benches you know
conservative mps holding a conservative
government to account all the same with
labor uh the dangers you have those kind
of things um with the s p up in scotland
um and i think that the danger is that
with some of the alexander stuff what
went on was frankly um a very dangerous
mix of a separation of powers being
blurred um and
frankly the mechanism in scotland was
shown to be lacking and the question is
that now we have as jackie says an s p
green uh pro-independence governments
are just about propped up
will we see any of those failures being
addressed and typically what's happened
in scotland over the last 15 years is
that failures or institutions which are
shown to be wanting have not been
rectified have not had any kind of sort
of minor political constitutional reform
and so it's the institutions that have
been found wanting and the danger is
that there seems to be no impetus from
the governing parties to rectify that
any time soon
james you you say in your piece that the
boundaries between the party and the
state up in scotland have in some cases
become indistinguishable you mentioned
the shipyard are there other cases
yes certainly is and i think that a
number of civil servants
up in scotland um you know most recently
leslie evans who was the permanent
secretary of the scottish government
until she recently left um earlier this
year um have close connections to um the
party and the danger is of course is
that if you have a nationalist party in
government the tendency is to see that
party as the party of government and the
only legitimate voice in scotland and i
think that jackie and a number of other
sort of politicians take a different
view on that have had those voices
attempting to be shut down and i don't
think that's particularly healthy or
productive for scott so at the end that
they
have to live with a result of policies
that politicians put through
jackie last question to you you said in
february last year during the fallout
between nicola sturgeon and alex salmond
that quote there's something rotten at
the core of the smp and it is poisoning
our democratic institutions end quote
now as somebody who works inside
scotland's political system every day
have you noticed any changes have things
become better since last february
no in fact they've become worse
i think the scottish government is less
accountable more centralizing much more
secretive you know i i lived through the
salmon inquiry and i have to say the
level of obstruction from the scottish
government was absolutely legendary you
know we were given um papers only after
we sought them
doggedly for months and months what we
were given was by and large redacted i
mean i recall a document of 22 pages
where 20 pages were actually snow white
because everything had been redacted
and they just simply refused to hand
over information i mean they didn't just
do it to a parliamentary committee they
did it in the courts as well and judges
had to order the government to hand over
information but you know one example i
would give you just recently
is where the permanent secretary who is
retiring was asked to appear before the
finance and public administration
committee of the parliament you would
think it was an opportunity for her to
talk about her achievements she refused
to attend a serving senior civil servant
simply refused to attend the committee
um and she wasn't held to account by the
scottish government um and therefore she
was clearly too busy just
preparing for her retirement i find that
scandalous that the highest civil
servant in scotland is not instructed by
ministers to attend a parliamentary
committee
jackie and james thanks for joining
[Music]
you